assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends thank you for joining me on this
amazing day the Sun is out reaching
millions of people as they enjoy their
vitamin D wouldn't it be amazing if the
way the Sun reaches millions of people
is done in the same way find the only
enlightening their day but enlightening
their whole life well it's not that easy
if you own the TV station maybe so but
the owner TV station doesn't come cheap
you have to pay sky fifty thousand
pounds per month just that's alone you
would have to spend millions of pounds
thousands of hours and hundreds of
employees to establish that whole team
in today's age media is really really
important so how we're going to reach
millions of people but what if I said to
you we have a little shortcut what if
you join our dau movement with your
support this will enable us to have a
full time market media and research team
and an office space which will enable us
to develop ourselves and take the dollar
to the next step and produce more
content more efficiently and
high-quality our platform alone right
now has reached nearly 40 million people
we are reaching two and a half million
people minimum per month with potential
of one hundred thousand views per day so
by joining the Dawa movement you will
become at our movement member and help
us get the Dower to the next step by
clicking the link below it's time we
take the Dawa to the next level and we
need your help and we need your support
join the bowel movement by becoming a
dowel movement member and help us take
the Dawa and the kalam of allah to the
next stage hope you guys enjoyed that
video don't forget to share subscribe
and like and join the dowel movement
while becoming at our movement member
today by clicking the link below